it's working
okay
okay good morning everyone welcome to
the committee of conference for House
Bill
281 I'm representative Michael Vose
chairing this committee on behalf of the
house conferees
the house conferees today are
representative Douglas Thomas
representative Kat McGee and
representative Michael Harrington the
Senate conferees are Senator Kevin avard
and Senator David Waters
and possibly
someone else
Senator Birdsall she's on her way
she's on her way so we're here and the
third Senate conferee is Senator
Birdsell
welcome
so I'd like to start this morning's
conference with a few remarks
about compromise and bipartisanship
yesterday
Governor sununu signed
the state budget
he Senator Bradley Senator Susie speaker
Packard and representative Wilhelm made
some comments during the course of the
signing ceremony and the governor in
particular talked about how this budget
was achieved with a lot of compromise
and a lot of bipartisan ship
Senator Bradley at one point even said
compromise is not
a dirty word a four-letter word
and I've been thinking about that
overnight
and realizing that
compromises the art of
giving a little and getting a little
and there's no person that I have seen
recently
in this legislature who is better at
that than Senator David Waters he is a
consummate compromiser
and Senator Waters I know was
instrumental in helping to put together
the compromise that we have before
before us in house bill 281.
and so I commend
Senator waters for his work on this bill
I have learned a lot about how to
compromise by interacting with Senator
Waters
I respect him greatly and I appreciate
all you do for your constituents and for
the legislature
as a whole
thank you Mr chairman I'm embarrassed
and uh it's just it's a team you're
seeing a senate team I know you have a
house a house team and it's difficult
but that's the spirit of of why we're
all here and um that's what this is a
this is a different this is a difficult
Bill well we thank you it has proven so
and um but the Senate position is here
and I think it's because we worked very
hard to get to something that not just
that we felt we could legislatively
bring forward but that would have the
support
of uh the agencies and the governor but
but here we are but I appreciate your
words Mr chairman and we thank you for
the the hard work you've done
there's a lot of talk about
bipartisanship
bipartisanship means both sides come
together and they agree to do something
and even though there's a lot of talk
about it
you don't see a lot of bipartisanship
actually happening when the opportunity
presents itself
but in my mind HB 281 is a great
opportunity
for us to show some bipartisanship
we each give a little and we each get a
little
and that's the way legislation moves
forward
I've been in the house now for nine
years
and I've watched the progression of
pieces of legislation
obviously mostly in the energy sector
but in other parts of of Statute as well
and nothing big typically happens in a
given year
small steps year by year are what
determine what good policy looks like
it's a constant process of revision
and House Bill 281 I think is a bill
that implements several small steps that
get us to a better policy position that
we were in before
now there were 23 members of the Senate
who said they wanted this bill to pass
and there were 176 members of the House
that's 199 legislators
there was one member of the Senate at
180 members of the House who said they
did not want it to pass that's 181
which leaves us with a net of plus 18
[Music]
people who wanted this bill to pass and
go forward
so here we sit with seven people who are
charged with
making the wishes of those 199
legislators who want this bill to pass
figuring out how to make that happen
and so that's why we're here for this
Committee of conference this morning
so those are my opening remarks about
this Committee of conference I will make
one other remark
it was there was a misunderstanding
about what this meeting was
by some people
apparently they didn't realize it was a
committee of conference they thought it
was a a public meeting on House Bill 281
and so some people came prepared this
morning to offer testimony about
hb281 which we cannot accept
and I apologize to people for that
misunderstanding if there was such a
misunderstanding but it's it's just not
the nature of a committee of conference
that you accept testimony from from
outside parties
so with that said I would uh open the
floor to members conferees to have a
discussion about how you want to move
forward with House Bill 281
Senator avard I I'm just uh
I'm in awe that we're at this this point
because I was listening to you on the
floor and uh I thought you spoke very
eloquently about this particular Bill
and uh as you just spoke and
the opportunity lies right here with a
lot of people in agreement and hopefully
the governor as well
um
to expand that metering and Municipal
house I mean some one I don't know if
we're going to get this opportunity
again
uh I'm hoping if there is room for comp
if there is a room for complimize we can
do it but I
I thought we really laid a good
foundation here and
I was kind of floored that we're here
but to be frank with you uh I'm hoping
wickets to move forward and uh in a
positive light and we've had a lot of
success in the last few days
with that same spirit and uh
I'm all ears
thank you senator
anybody else have comments that they'd
like to make
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
um it's been very very fun to hear
everybody speak on the bill it's it's a
process going through I'm the person who
um stood up in opposition to concurrence
on 281 and so I brought an amendment
this morning that I'd like to just
explain to folks about what the
exceptions were for the people who were
opposed in the house
and just for consideration of whether or
not we can make it an even better bill I
have copies here so I can send them
around the chairs got them on and can
send those that way
here's another one for you Doug
um so the two items that I would propose
that we remove from the bill are the
ones that are not not Central to I think
the original intent of the bill the
sections section three
which is the which is representative
Thomas's Bill originally that asked us
to put the cost of the renewable
portfolio standards on everyone's
electric bill on their December bill it
would be a annual total
um the original point of the bill was to
create transparency for the customers so
they would have an understanding of what
the RPS charges were
and the way the bill worked out through
the process is that it would have cost
some money to create an individual uh
summary for every every Bill and so the
utilities came back and said we'll take
an average user's Bill we'll average the
RPS charge and we'll put that cumulative
average charge on every bill
and the exception
um that we had in the house was that
rather than lending transparency to the
bill it would not be the actual charge
that the customer was charged so
everyone's bill would have a cost on
there but it could be higher or lower
than what you actually paid and we
thought that would be more confusing and
that it wouldn't actually achieve the
goal so that was the argument
that we made on the house floor and so
that was HB 251 that was part of 281 so
it was one-fifth of this bill but it
also was heard separately and it lost in
the house when the argument was made
that it would not contribute to
transparency that it might really
confuse confuse people further because
the amount could be more or less than
what you were charged and how you know
how well would the customer be able to
interpret that so we thought it was
confusing so that's number three
um in the amended analysis list of
what's in the bill
and then number four is
um the disillusion of the easy board the
Energy Efficiency and sustainable energy
board and that's a board that chairman
Vose and I both serve on as well as
Senator avard the board has been uh
has been in service basically to the
state for 15 years so it was instituted
in 2008 and
um we had there were hearings on the
easy board I wasn't I was out on medical
leave the time so I never really got to
speak to
um what I thought about the the easy
board but
um sort of the
the arguments against it seem to be that
it's you know not needed and
um in a recent meeting a month ago
one of our members Matt Cisco who's from
an engineering firm that does Energy
Efficiency work did a presentation on
the impediments to New Hampshire's clean
energy Workforce and talked about how
that's going to be something that's
going to be preventing us from being
able to move forward with plans that
we're trying to implement so just like
everyone else is having Workforce issues
the clean energy sector also has those
so it was an incredible slide deck
everybody was very impressed with it he
had been working on it for weeks
and at the same time
Doria Brown who's the energy manager for
the city of Nashua had been heading up a
subcommittee that the House and Senate
had asked with the passage of Senate
Bill 549 the easy board to take on they
asked us to stop doing the triennial
energy report that recommended what we
should be investing in the New Hampshire
saves program they so they put into
statute that that would now be handled
by a calculation that was adopted with
that bill
um and they asked us to take a pot of
money
that was funded by that bill and go
forward and create an Energy Efficiency
uh plan for reaching out to the public
on the benefits of Energy Efficiency so
we had this subcommittee headed up again
by Doria Brown that was working on an
RFP
and so the discussions recently in the
easy board were that the doe was
prepared to take over that RFP and move
with it from there
but what I would
like to say on behalf of this particular
change is
one of the reasons that the house or the
the majority or the members that voted
uh last Thursday
uh were opposed to the way 281 came to
us is that two of the items in the bill
including the easy board change were
bills that were retained in committee
right so we made the argument to them
these bills never got through the house
they didn't have a full vote through the
house so they were kind of plucked out
of retained committee status and put
into 281. so that was an objection that
that we made and that I guess worked by
a couple of votes
um
so where we're at is that we are
eliminating a vibrant Board of experts
who bring
um
you know incredibly relevant experience
to the table in Folsom conversation
around energy issues which are not any
less complex today than they were in
2008.
um and in our last meeting Kate Peterson
I'm sorry Kate Peters from eversource
who has been on the board the entire
time and has taken various leadership
roles over the years
stated how valuable it is and how other
states don't do it this way that she has
a place where she can have first-hand
conversations with Community Action
agencies and New Hampshire Builders and
and all the other folks who are giving
of their time
so what I want to propose is that we
remove that section as well leave the
bill in its retained status in the house
and allow us to try and determine
um
in a bill that would be an early bill
for January
what the new charge of the easy board
should be rather than disbanding them
when they're in the middle of working
for us
um you know perhaps they could morph
into grid mod which I think was uh
suggested by one of our Watchers here
you know we're looking to put together
other boards of experts to try and help
us with grid modernization perhaps that
could be you know the new charge for
this group of people rather than letting
them go because it
um
implied in dissolving that board is that
they're not needed and I would propose
that they still are
so
um so that would leave
us with
um
it would the least cost integrated
resource planning repeal would be
maintained and the municipal host
expansion for municipalities would be
maintained and the proposed SEC changes
would be maintained
so that the two
things that are kind of not like the
others would would be removed
I know it's a lot but okay that's that's
my explanation thank you for explaining
that is there any discussion of that
proposal or is there a motion on that
proposal I noticed that the least cost
integrated the resource planning
planning yeah
um I don't know if you were there in
committee when we were talking about
that and how that in some respects it is
outdated and is not as effective and I
believe we made a commitment uh both
myself with Senator Waters and Senator
representative Rose how that we would
readdress this this particular issue
next session yep uh
uh
uh that is unaffected by what I'm
proposing right yeah right yeah removal
of that yep yep okay
um
well I think I understand that that is
the compromise right that is that that
is the goal yeah I'm curious have you
spoken with the executive branch at all
their disposition on this because no I
don't get a lot of opportunity they're
going to have to assign it or
you know
have you worked with them at all on this
no
so representative McGee do you want to
make a motion about this uh sure
Amendment yeah I'd like to make a motion
that we have a vote on whether or not to
accept
um the amendment in order to uh
Street Street
what's up each body votes separately
right
but before we can vote period we need a
second to your motion oh does anybody
second that motion
everyone's holding their prouder
seeing none
the motion uh will not go forward Okay
so
uh
I would like to now recognize uh
representative
um Doug Thomas and representative Thomas
I think wants to make a motion
thank you Mr chairman
the motion is that the house recedes
from its position of non-concur and
usceeds to the Senate amendments and
agrees to the passage of the bill as
amended by the Senate
it's been made and second it's possible
constantly break of 15 minutes
okay so we do we votes in this term we
you know I I guess we seconded over here
but we vote separately on the amount on
the the motion so um
thank you
for 15 minutes and we will return it at
the left of 10 35.
okay to finish our session thank you I
forgot to turn on my mic so I'll repeat
what I just said we're going to take a
caucus break for 15 minutes and we will
return to complete the business of this
Committee of conference at 10 35. thank
you
Zoom the committee of conference on
House Bill 281 I will remind the members
that there is a motion on the floor
the motion reads the house recedes from
its position of non-concur and accedes
to the Senate amendments and agrees to
the passage of the bill as amended by
the Senate is there any need for
discussion on this motion
seeing none I'll ask the members of the
house to vote representative Harrington
in favor representative McGee aye
representative Thomas yes representative
votes yes
members of the Senate
yes
so the motion passes the house recedes
from its position of non-concurrentices
to the Senate amendments and agrees to
the passage of the bill is amended by
the Senate and I thank you all for your
participation in this Committee of
conference it was an excellent
discussion and we have lots of work to
do going forward
um
in fixing some of the things that this
bill has changed so that will happen
next year and we'll look forward to that
discussion thank you all for attending
if I may say Mr chairman that I'm sure
that and having had some conversation
with them
Senator a bar and other members of enr
that we are fully committed to doing the
things to work together and quickly to
do some of the things we need to do
so thank you yeah
excellent excellent and we have members
of the public who have submitted some
good ideas and and we look forward to
examining those uh
in the coming months so we thank you for
that Mr chairman I would just say one
thing I think you know we've done a lot
of work on the site evaluation committee
and just for for public dissertation I
was at the ferc meeting yesterday up in
uh Portland and a lot of people up there
expressed a lot of concern about citing
in New England and New Hampshire
specifically as well and I'm not saying
that this is the perfect fix to
everything but I think it's a step in
the right direction and I'd certainly
encourage everybody to look at is there
ways we can make it better because
regardless of what you want to build
citing is going to be and I think people
are coming to this realization this is
going to be the big issue whether you're
building offshore wind you still need to
build transmission someplace people
sometimes think oh we have all this
offshore wind it'll just appear in our
house somehow uh whether it's solar
whether it's natural gas or I don't know
what the project is it's all going to
involve siding and we've got to make
deciding so it protects our environment
and our state but also makes things
possible without taking years and years
and years to get it because that's just
skiers investors off and they want come
here
well said and with that we'll adjourn
and I thank you all again thank you